The day of the Muslim ban, there were
so many emotions that I was feeling.
[News Clip]: "President
Trump is defending "
"a temporary travel ban for seven"
"Muslim majority countries."
I thought about my family,
who's had seven Marines
that served in Iraq and Afghanistan,
the New York Police Department;
how this was a betrayal to their service
to this nation.
A Muslim ban that basically said,
"You are not welcome here
because you are Yemeni."
I consider myself
one of those people
who's been put on the face of the earth
to be a change agent.
"No hate no fear."
"Our country was built on
the backs of immigrants."
The day of the Muslim ban,
I organized an emergency meeting
with the Yemeni-American community.
They were so outraged.
When Yemeni-Americans
migrated to New York,
they landed at Brooklyn Borough Hall.
Many of them then went
off to open up stores
which are now called "bodegas".
There are between four
to six thousand bodegas
across New York City
owned by Yemeni-Americans.
They never, ever were interested
in challenging government,
but the Muslim ban woke them up.
They felt that they
needed to take a stand.
And so, Zaid, a fellow
Yemeni-American, said,
"Why don't we do a strike?"
"Close about two hundred stores."
I said, "Okay so when do
you guys want to do this?"
And he said, "Thursday."
I was like, "What?"
We had four days.
(upbeat music)
My media head starts thinking
about this and I'm like,
"If you really want to
send a strong message,"
"you close a thousand
stores and we hold a rally."
I called up the Borough
President, Eric Adams.
"Eric, I need your help."
"It has to be Brooklyn Borough Hall."
He's like, "Okay, that's
cutting it really close."
And I was like, "What's going on that day?
They're like,
"We have the Chinese New Year
event happening that night."
I called back Zaid and he said,
"Brooklyn Borough Hall?"
And I was like, "Yes" and he was like,
"Wow, that's really big."
We made over a thousand posters
and we distributed to the stores
and the store owners
pasted it on their windows:
"We're closing from 12:00 to 8:00 pm."
They were literally delivering posters
as late as Thursday 3:00 am.
We were talking about who was going to MC,
and they're like, "You're gonna MC."
"What do you mean, 'who's gonna MC'?"
"You're MCing this."
I was like, "Oh, my God."
The day of the rally, it is
freezing cold in the plaza.
At 12 o'clock, the stores shut down.
- [News Clip] "Yemeni owners of bodegas"
"across the city closing
up shop at 12 noon."
There were two bodegas,
they never close their doors, never.
When they went to lock the doors,
the lock fell apart.
12:30, I get a call:
"Debbie, what time did
you tell people to come?"
- And I said, "4:30."
He's like, "Debbie, we
have fifty people outside."
The numbers just kept growing.
At 1:30, Stefan calls me again,
"There are five hundred people outside!"
"People are hanging off
the fringe of the flags."
(crowd yelling)
I finally make my way there
at 3:00 O'clock.
And all I see is a sea of people,
I was like, "Oh, my God,
how did this happen?"
"Did we really do this?"
Close to six thousand people.
Young, old, American
flags swinging everywhere.
This is (in Arabic) Borough Hall.
Borough Hall for the Yemenis!
[Debbie]: "You should
be absolutely proud!"
We were covered by the 'New York Times',
by 'Slate',
'LA Times'.
Every media outlet covered us.
[Crowd]: "This is what
democracy looks like!"
My eyes swelled with tears
and I felt so much pride
to see my community actually
take a political stand.
[Debbie]: "You are powerful!"
We took that energy and
formed the Yemeni-American
Merchants Association to
make sure they have a voice
and a place at the table.
And to say, "This sleeping
giant is no longer sleeping."